hello
first up we've got star girl
hi i'm new to california i usually sing
with a ukulele but here's to trying new
things
i was lying in my room and the news
came on tv
i guess i didn't think we'd be moving
again so quickly i thought you liked
going on adventures a lot of people
going on adventures is one thing but
having your whole life being adventure
is another but life is an adventure love
and mercy i love you singing thank you
i'm evan i'm star girl cool name what's
going on out here evan she's our new
neighbor hi
[Music]
my brother and i are making this movie
and it's got music in it but we need a
girl for it and you could be the perfect
person
so you want to be in our movie all right
let's do it
oh my god that's roxanne martel who she
put out one album and then nothing she's
here every night write your own stuff no
i just really like other people's stuff
you're gonna have to figure out your own
thing
nobody can tell you
there's only one song
singing all set let's roll but you gotta
make your own kind of music
sing
your special
[Music]
all i wanted was to dream crazy things
and find people crazy enough to dream
them with me
you gave me something i thought only
existed in pictures
and i got more than that
something i never expected
even nobody else sings alone
that was a keeper let's take a break
you